[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW MOSCHETTI: My name's
Andrew Moschetti, a solutions
architect with Google
Cloud's Health Care
and Life Sciences Team, and I
want to review for you today
some of the tools
that we have for doing
different types of genomic
analyses on Google Cloud.
So first, a brief
introduction to our team.
The Health Care and
Life Sciences Team
is a multi-functional team
investing in building products
that are specific
to these industries.
We also work to help deploy
these solutions with customers
and then scale through partners
to help expand and expedite
that development.
Today, we're going to
focus on a number of tools
for biomedical research, ranging
from public dataset hosting
to our pipeline's API product,
some workflow orchestration
tools for doing both genomics
and other research workloads.
We'll cover a few open
source tools that we have
and some integrations
in the space as well.
And finally, we'll get into
some large-scale analytics
at the end.
So on the topic of
public datasets,
GCP hosts a number
of public datasets
from a variety of industries,
some of those from genomics.
These public datasets are
available for you to query up
to a terabyte a month for free.
And then as a data
host, you also
have the ability to
bring your own datasets,
and we have a public
hosting program
that you can get in touch
with if there's something
that you think is
beneficial, or you can also
just host your own, make
it public if you'd like,
or access control
that however you'd
like to control who you
want to give that to.
And when you're hosting
these public datasets,
whoever is doing
the actual usage--
so the analytics-- is going
to be responsible for any
of the costs of the
querying or the egress costs
if they're in buckets.
So as a data host, you know that
you only pay for the storage,
and you're not responsible
for any of the computation
that someone might do.
So in genomics, we host
a number of datasets,
including 1,000 genomes, the
Illumina Platinum Genomes,
TCGA, the MSSNG
Database for Autism,
Simons Genome Diversity
Project, as well as some others.
And we provide these in
both the raw files that
are available in Google
Cloud Storage buckets,
and then we provide
them in BigQuery
as well, where
those datasets are
available for you to do analysis
or to actually compare those
with some of your own
datasets that you could bring.
In the similar
space, we also host
a number of annotation sources,
including ClinVar and COSMIC,
and these can be used for
sample annotation pipelines,
and there's a number of
sample queries available
online as well showing how to
join these with other datasets,
such as those that you
might bring on your own.
So this is our page for the
Genomics Public Datasets Page,
and we'll take a look
at it here in a second.
But at the top, you
can see we've got links
to both the BigQuery
and the storage buckets,
or we can actually browse
it by specific datasets
to see a little more detail.
So if we look at this here,
and we go to that dataset page,
again, the top has both the
storage and the BigQuery.
In the bottom, we can go to
one of the individual datasets.
So if we go to 1,000
Genomes for example,
you'll be able to see all the
specifications of which tables
we have in there broken down by
where they are, what versions,
and then what's in a
storage bucket versus what's
available in BigQuery.
If we go into that here,
you can see, for example,
the Phase 3 of 1,000 Genomes,
we can go to the VCFs
and go ahead and browse
through that full sample
size, the full sample set.
And these are available for
you to test your own workflows
or to use as well.
In BigQuery, we can go here
to see the variant annotation
datasets, and this actually
includes both the annotations
as well as the other datasets.
So on the left here,
you can see one
is the annotations, the
other one being the variance,
and the various tables that
are a part of each of those.
So next, I'd like to cover
one of our main products
in this space, And
that's Pipelines API.
It's also referred to
as Genomics API, which
was an earlier name of the
product due to the usage being
almost exclusively
for genomics to start.
The product now is available for
any sort of research workload,
and it works well
for genomic pipelines
but also can handle
other things as well.
So even though we
can do other things,
one of the more common uses of
it is to do secondary analysis.
And in this case,
we can use it to run
standard tools such as GATK
or other optimized machine
learning tools such
as Deep Variant.
By using Pipelines API, we
can optimize for time and cost
through a number
of different ways.
These include things
like parallel execution,
being able to use GPUs or
TPUs, or Tensor Processing
Units, persistent disk
and different disk types,
as well as different instances
such as preemptable instances,
which are instances
that are much cheaper
but may get shut down if
there's a spike in demand.
We also work with a
number of workflow engines
to incorporate directly
with Pipelines API,
and you can see some
of those partners
here, and then
also some partners
who provide their own solutions
in this space, such as Fire
Cloud, Ntera, DNA Stack,
Seven Bridges, BC Platforms,
and a number of others.
The work that we're
doing in this space
is informed by the interest
that we see in the industry.
So if there are things
that you're using
or partners you're working
with that aren't available,
reach out.
We'd love to hear
some feedback on that
so we know what
we can do to help
drive the industry forward.
So some of the workflow
engines that we integrate with
include Cromwell, dsub,
Nextflow is a newer one
that we now incorporate
with, and then we're
working with a number
of others as well
to bring that support to
the other workflow engines.
Now, the advantage of working
with a workflow engine
is it abstracts away the process
of you having to start VMs,
manage the whole
process of that,
and what you provide
is the container that
has the task you want to run.
You include the VM, and so any
of the specifications you have
for that VM, ranging from a
very high level definition
where you might just say you
want a standard 1 instance,
all the way down
to the point where
you can configure the number
of CPUs, which CPU architecture
you need if you're taking
advantage of some of the newer
Intel chips, the ability
to attach GPUs and TPUs
and specify which ones you
want, and different disk
types as well, which
could include SSDs, even
locally-attached SSDs if you
really need that throughput.
So when you're using
the workflow engine now,
it's easier for you to run
these in various environments
and not have to
change everything just
to move to Google Cloud.
You don't have to learn
the intricacies of the API
because we've done that work
with the workflow engines
themselves.
So you just define
the task you have,
and the workflow engine will
make those calls for you.
Another benefit of
this is that you
don't have to monitor the
status of all of the tasks
as they go through,
and the workflow engine
will track when an
operation starts,
what needs to come next,
when it should start one,
and if it needs to retry a
certain task due to failure
or preemption.
So when we use Pipelines API,
it starts these operations using
a container for each task.
Again, you define the resources
that you need for each task,
and this is something
that you can specify
at an individual
task level instead
of just the entire pipeline.
So you can really start
to optimize for each task,
and you can realize which parts
need high throughput, which
parts need memory,
and maybe only
a certain part that needs an
attach accelerator like a GPU,
or certain parts
of it that may be
more suitable to being preempted
if you can restart them.
So we'll take a
look here at a demo
of using Cromwell to
run the Germline SNPs
and INDELs from
GATK Best Practices,
and the demo we're
going to look at
is actually two
separate pipelines.
And so what we have
here is Cromwell
in a container and
the first pipeline,
we send the container
that includes Cromwell,
and the inputs that
we provide to that
are the WDL, the
workflow definition,
and then a list of
the inputs and options
we want for the run.
So that first VM we start is
actually a VM with Cromwell.
Once that's up and
running, it then we'll
start the full
pipeline here of GATK.
And then it'll run
through all of those.
Again, the one with
Cromwell-- when it's finished,
it knows that then it'll shut
down as well through pipelines.
So it allows you to
manage all of that
without having to install
something specifically.
Now, if you have
a working instance
of Cromwell installed
somewhere else,
you can definitely use that.
But this is an
opportunity we provide
to show how you can do it
without needing to install
anything on your own.
So to start this
here, we're going
to clone a couple
of repositories
with the code we're using
here and set some environment
variables about where we want
our input and outputs to go,
and then the command
that we start here,
there's a few options--
I know it's a little small
here, but we include things
like the region
and the zone where
we want the job to
run, the input files,
the output locations,
where we want
to save our logging as well.
And once we run
it at the bottom,
we get an operation ID,
so that number there.
This allows us to follow
up and track that operation
if we need to troubleshoot
or maybe come back later.
And in the UI here, if we go to
the Genomics part of the Cloud
console, you see a list
of operations here,
and we can track when
they've been completed.
We can look at the tags to
see what part of the task
they were.
So once that's all
completed, we can now
see the output of these in a
Google Cloud Storage bucket,
and this includes
our final output
that we were looking for.
It includes any of the
logs from different tasks
throughout as well as standard
out and standard error.
So if we need to go back and
troubleshoot a particular task,
we have the ability to
go back and see that.
And then any of the work
intermediates as well
that we may have saved--
either for checking or doing
QC and QA.
So here, we'll go to the storage
bucket, and as we go in here,
you'll see that in the
work, we've got this job ID,
and this is what correlates
to the job we just ran.
You can see here
a different folder
for each one of those calls,
so each of the tasks we used.
And coming in here, again,
we can see the output
from those and the
errors in logging,
so if we need to come
back and check that.
Going to the Output
folder, we have
all of the different outputs
from the various tasks
that were part of this.
This includes some
metrics and reports
that were generated as
a part of that process.
And then also, we
can go through here
to see the index and
our VCF as well, which
is kind of our end goal.
The next example is using dsub,
and so when we used dsub here,
we're actually going to install
dsub in the Cloud Shell.
So again, you don't
have to install anything
on your own machine, and you
can run the entire thing just
from the cloud.
So the example we're
going to use here
is using data from 1,000
Genomes to do indexing,
and we're going to use
SAMtools in a Docker container
to do that.
So we're going to start, again,
by cloning the repository
with what we need, and
I'm going to install dsub
in a virtual environment.
Again, this is running
in that Cloud console,
so I don't have to worry about
installing or maintaining that.
The command to run it here is
very similar to the last one,
if you see some of
the options here.
We provide a zone.
We provide an input and
an output, the container
that we want to use.
And then once that's
running, we can actually
go and track the resources
that it's generating as well.
So if we come to the
Compute Engine page,
you can see this is the
instance as well that's
been started that's
actually running that job.
And then going to Storage, we
can go ahead and see the output
from that as well as some of
the logs such as standard out
and error if we need to
troubleshoot some of that.
Next up is Deep Variant.
So Deep Variant is a SNPs
and INDEL variant color
that uses deep neural networks.
And this is developed
as a collaboration
between Google Research
and Verily Life Sciences.
And the Cloud Health Care
and Life Sciences Team
partnered with them to
optimize this for cost
and speed running on GCP.
And if you look at
the documentation
pages for Deep Variant in
our Cloud documentation,
there's a couple of
different settings
we provide there of a version
that's optimized for time
and a version that's
optimized for cost.
And we can do this by using
different resources, attaching
GPUs, for example.
And by changing that, we
can find the right trade-off
between cost and time that
works for your business
or your research.
So in this case,
we're going to run
Deep Variant from a
Docker container--
very similar to the last ones.
So we'll take a look
at the script here
that's going to
start Deep Variant.
Again, we set a
number of variables
at the beginning, such as
our project, the input,
the reference genome
that we want to use,
the zone where we're
going to have this run.
And then at the
bottom is the command
that's making the
call to Pipelines API,
and that will look very similar
to the last ones as well.
So once we start it, we
get that operation ID.
In this one, we'll
jump ahead here,
and we can go ahead and look
at the output in our storage
bucket and get to
that VCF file as well.
One of the newest additions
we have here is Nextflow.
We recently added this
a couple of months ago.
If you're not familiar, Nextflow
is a multi-platform workflow
engine that supports a
variety of back ends,
ranging from various Cloud
providers to on prem,
to HPC clusters, to
even running locally.
And what we built in here in
working with the community
to develop this is
the ability for you
to choose Google
Pipelines and Google Cloud
Platform as the back end where
you want to run those tasks.
So this allows you to
take an existing workflow
that you have that may be
running somewhere else,
and you can now move that
to run with Pipelines API
by changing the
executor and then
a couple of the settings
in there as well--
again, things like
project machine types.
And then, in this case,
it will use Pipelines API
as the back end for that, and so
all of your computation, then,
will run through Pipelines
on Google Compute Engine.
There's also an
option with Nextflow
where Nextflow can set
up a cluster directly
on GCE with configurable
master and worker nodes,
so that's an option
you can use as well.
The example we're
going to look at here
is with running an RNAseq
proof of concept that's using
Pipelines API as the back end.
Again, we're going to do this
whole thing in the Cloud Shell.
So we don't actually have
to install the Nextflow
application on our local
machine, although you can
if you'd like.
But we'll show a demo here
of doing it all in the Cloud.
And then we're going to use that
installed version of Nextflow
that's in Cloud Shell to go
ahead and run our pipeline.
So let's take a
look at the config
here, our Nextflow config,
and you'll see at the top
there where we set
Google Pipelines,
and this is where you
would change that depending
where you want it to run.
We then set a couple
of specific options,
such as the instance types we
want to use and the project.
And then we'll go ahead and
start that version of Nextflow
right now running in the Cloud.
As the tasks go through, you'll
see an ID on the left there,
and we can use those to
track the resources like we
saw before, going into the
operations and Compute Engine
to actually see which instances
are doing which m tasks
and follow up on those.
Next up, we'll get into
a Variant Transforms.
So Variant Transforms is a
tool that we open-sourced
for transforming and processing
VCF files to bring them
into BigQuery to do analytics.
Now, Variant Transforms
runs using Dataflow,
which if you're not familiar,
supports the Apache Beam
SDK in both batch and streaming
mode, although in this case,
we're going to use it in batch.
And then variant
Transforms also supports
both Direct runner
and Dataflow runner,
and you can pick
which one of those
is ideal for the
operation you're running.
So some of the challenges that
we face in tertiary analysis
include trying to analyze
large amounts of data
and join that with
public datasets
or perhaps with
datasets that we're
receiving from a collaborator
or at a different facility.
The ability to
join those variants
with different
annotation sources
where we're trying to
understand an annotation
specific to that organism--
we have tasks like QA
and QC that we're doing.
We may have multi-sample
processing as well.
And then doing things
like association analysis,
population analysis, GWAS.
So for all of those
things, BigQuery
is a great tool for that.
We'll get into that
in a second here.
But to be able to
support that, we really
need a way to import
this data into BigQuery
in a reliable, reproducible
way with a standard format.
And Variant Transforms
is what is that for us.
So Variant Transforms uses
parallel batch processing
and Dataflow to do this,
reading in VCF files,
either single files,
multiple files, and then
we'll end up dumping
those into BigQuery table.
Now, in addition
to importing, we
realize that sometimes
you may have a tool that
still needs VCF files.
The reality is a lot of things
have already been written,
and they may not have an
integration with BigQuery,
and so you may need
the VCF files back.
Variant Transforms also
supports pulling things back
out of BigQuery to
give you a VCF file.
So you can maybe
identify a subgroup
from your data that's in
BigQuery, export that to a VCF
that you can then put
into your other tools,
and really use BigQuery
as that storage as well.
Another recent addition
to Variant Transforms
is support for
doing annotations,
and right now, we have support
for doing VEP annotation,
either importing something
that's been annotated
or performing annotation on a
dataset that you already have.
As we continue this
development, we're
looking at other
annotation sources as well.
So if there are others
that you're interested in
or something that
would be useful,
again, we'd love to hear
the feedback there and see
what would be useful for you.
At the end of the talk,
we've got a mailing list,
and I'll point that
out, but if you've
got feedback or questions, feel
free to send it to that group,
and we'd love to hear from you.
So this example here,
looking at this screenshot,
is running Variant
Transforms on the 2,500
samples of 1,000 Genomes.
And this particular set is
about 81 million variants,
so it ends up being an
81 million row table.
And the screenshot
we're looking at
is the Dataflow console
in Google Cloud console.
And you can see
here-- this task is
about 100 days of compute time,
and we've completed it here
in just under two hours.
But you'll notice
we could go faster.
If we look at the right,
that blue line on the chart
where that kind of plateaus--
so that line is the
number of workers
that we had working
on the task, and you
can see it hit a
limit there, which was
the quota that I've assigned.
And in this case, I have had
a quota set for disk space,
for how much SSD I was willing
to use at the same time.
So you can use things like these
quotas to help control costs
or figure out how much you're
willing to do at a single time.
In this particular case, it
scaled up to about 400, workers
and then that's
where it stopped.
If you wanted to increase
that, we can increase the time.
It will be done faster.
And again, that's where you
get into the balance of cost
versus time.
Now, in running it
with more disk space,
you're obviously going to
pay for more disk space,
but you'll have much
less compute time.
And so that's where you start to
balance the differences in cost
of compute versus
cost of storage.
So the next sample
we'll take a look at
is basically running this
on a smaller subset of data
that's about 100 variants.
We use that just for scale.
So when we take a
look at the script
we're going to use to
run Variant Transforms,
we list things like the
input bucket with our VCF,
the output table in
BigQuery, a temp location,
and then some information
about our product.
At the bottom, you'll also see
a Google Pipelines command.
We're actually running
Variant Transforms
through Google Pipelines,
just like we did before.
So once that starts,
we get that operation,
we can come to Compute Engine,
and we can see the main node
here that we've
started, and this
is the worker that's
actually going
to kick off that Dataflow job.
So then coming into
Dataflow, we can
start to get into the
specifics of that run.
We can follow it to see
where it's at in the process,
understand the
resource consumption.
And once it's done,
we'll go into BigQuery
to see the output.
Coming into the
dataset and table,
you'll see the
schema listed here.
And this is the schema
that we use for variants,
and you can see the information
as well as the types,
for example, so you know
how to query that field.
We can look at some
details about that,
showing us the size of the
table, the rows, the location
where it's stored.
And then this
preview field lets us
see a sample set of the data.
So it shows us how
the data is stored.
And if you're more
of a visual learner,
this is a spot you
can come to see
what that looks like before
you start writing your queries.
So once it's there, BigQuery is
our serverless, scalable data
warehouse.
And BigQuery scales to
petabytes of storage.
It provides a standard SQL
dialect for doing queries,
so you don't have to learn
a new language to use it.
One of the features is that
it actually separates compute
and storage from each other.
And so in this case,
particularly in a research
environment, it
is very important
because as a data host, you
know exactly what you're
going to be on the hook for.
You upload a data
set, you're going
to pay the storage cost
of that, and you're only
going to pay the storage cost.
You're not worried about what
analytics someone else is
going to run against that.
And as a user, you know that
you're paying for an analysis
that you're doing,
and we show you
how much you can expect
to pay for those as well.
As a data host, we also
offer a lot of different ways
to do access control, and you
can do some fine-grained access
control as well if
you're providing
your data set to different
collaborators, for example.
One of the ways
that we do that is
through using authorized
views, and authorized views
are a way to let you share your
query results without actually
sharing the underlying data.
So let's say you have a
table with some dataset,
and you want to give
access to a subset of that,
whether that's certain
columns that aren't relevant
for that person, maybe
its certain rows,
or due to different consent
or usage agreements,
you're only allowed to
provide certain samples
to a particular user.
In that case, you write a query
that pulls out that subgroup,
and you save your results
as an authorized view.
The end user that you now give
access to the authorized view
queries that view as
though it were a table.
So they don't know
anything different.
They think that's the table.
They use the same
syntax and everything
as though they were
querying the table,
but they don't get access
to the underlying data,
and you decide what
they get to see.
Some other features in
BigQuery are query validation.
So on the right here, you
can see this green checkbox,
and that's going to
let us know that it's
a valid query we wrote.
If it's not valid, we
get a little red x.
If you hover over
that, it will start
to give you some
feedback as well
and let you know what's
missing in the syntax,
give you some tips as to
how to maybe fix that.
And then, next to
that, the green text
as well tells you
how much data it's
expected to process
when you run this query.
So the pricing
model for BigQuery
is storage and data processing.
So time is not something
that you're charged on,
but you're charged on the amount
of data that gets processed.
And so we show you
here how much data
we expect to process if
you were to run this query,
and it lets you understand,
is this really a query you
want to run?
Or is it something
where maybe you
need to optimize your query
before you actually run that?
We provide a number
of different ways
to actually integrate
with BigQuery.
We have the UI
here, so if that's
something you're
more familiar with,
you can run your
queries from here.
You don't have to leave
your browser window open
when you run them.
Your queries will
get started as a job.
You can come back
and find them later.
If you run the same
query again, results
are cached for an amount
of time as well so
that if you were
running the same thing,
you're not necessarily getting
charged every time you do that.
We also provide a command line
tool for running your queries.
And so in that case,
that's something
you can run on
your local machine
through the Google
Cloud SDK, or you
can do it through the Cloud
console, which already
has that tool installed.
There's also an API
for it, as well as
a number of client libraries.
The client libraries we include
right now our Java, Go, Python,
Ruby, Node.js, and C#.
The advantages of this
mean that if you've already
got an application in
one of those languages,
you don't have to write
a separate integration
for BigQuery.
You can import the BigQuery
library for your language,
have your query
happen right there,
and get your results
in the query.
So when we're using
BigQuery as a variant store,
one of the things we
need to standardize here
is the schema that
we're going to use.
And this schema
here that we have
is based on standard
VCF, and the way
we represent this through
a few different data types,
so we have simple fields
such as integers and strings.
We have nested fields which show
up in here listed as a record.
And then, we also can have
repeated fields as well.
So in this case, we may have
multiple alternate bases,
and within alternate
bases, there
are different ones we
want to keep track of.
So we represent those as
a repeated nested field.
We also store the information
from the VCF header--
so things that are in format
and info, for example.
You can see at the bottom
here under alternate bases,
those are things that we've
pulled out of the header,
and then we'll go
ahead and store those.
Again, we can also put
those back into the VCF
if you need to pull that
back out of BigQuery.
This is suitable for storing
single sample or multiple
samples, and Variant Transforms,
when you're importing,
is also able to validate a
VCF before you import it.
So for example,
if you have a lot
of samples you're importing at
once, the last thing you want
is to get all the way
to the end and then
have it fail because you have
some malformed records in one
of your files.
So we can actually do
a quick validation step
where it'll go
through before and let
you know if there's any
issues, and you can decide
what you want to
do at that point
if it finds a malformed record.
Whether you want to try
to guess what to do,
if you want to ignore it, if
you want to abort the task--
that's something that
you can configure there.
And then again, as I mentioned,
the ability to export that
back to VCF as well.
Because we have this
standard schema,
we can get it back
to that same spot.
If you're querying multiple
independently-repeated fields,
in that case, you're
going to actually need
to unnest those fields.
And so we'll flatten
either the table
or flatten part of
the table, and we've
got some documentation
on our page
as well about how
to flatten that,
whether you're trying to
flatten an entire table or just
specific fields.
So the following
slides, we're going
to go through a few examples
of running some queries,
and the sample set here is
just over 10,000 samples,
which is about 361 million
variants that we're using.
And the initial import of
that is a 23-terabyte table.
Now, these were imported
using Variant Transforms,
and I actually did
this in four batches,
and that snapshot we saw
earlier from Dataflow
was one of the batches where I
was actually adding 2,500 more
samples to this existing table.
Now, when you're
doing those imports,
again, you decide if
you want a new table
or if you want to append
it to an existing one.
And when you append it
to an existing table,
it's an atomic operation.
So nothing is actually
there until the whole job's
completed.
So you don't have to worry
about it failing at the end
and ending up with a
mismatch of records,
or if someone's running
a query while you're
updating the records, they'll
get one version or the other,
depending when
they run the query,
but you're never going
to get a mix of both.
So we're going to go
through the next few slides
and look at some tips
for optimizing queries,
and the things are
going to optimize
for are runtime storage and the
amount of data that we process.
Now, as I mentioned,
the costs of BigQuery
are related to the
amount of data you
process and the
storage, so those
are easy things we
would think to optimize
because they
drastically can reduce
the cost that we pay for this.
In addition, runtime
can also be important
depending what you're using
the output of this query for.
If you have other processes
in your business or something
else in your lab that
depends on this output,
there might be times when
the runtime is actually
more important to you than the
cost, or equally as important.
So we'll look at how to
optimize there as well.
So this first query where to
look at-- a fairly simple one,
and we're just counting
all the variants,
and we're going to order
them by chromosome.
And so I do this because
this is a query that
shows where we're actually
going to have to go through,
and we're going to have
to process all of the rows
because we're going to
count all of the variants.
So we're going to go
through and count everything
where there is a genotype
greater than zero,
and then we're going to
group those by chromosome.
And so in here, you'll see
that group by reference name,
and that's where we'll
go ahead and order those.
And once they're ordered,
we'll actually go through,
and we'll count them in each
group and report them back.
So when we run this on the
initially imported table,
it processes about
13 terabytes of data,
and it takes a little
over four minutes to run.
That is expensive
and time-consuming.
We can do much better
in both of those,
and we'll show you a
couple of techniques
of how you can deal with that.
So the first
optimization technique
we have is partitioning
and clustering of tables.
Now, in this case,
at the bottom,
you'll see that we cluster this
table on reference name, which
is the chromosome, and then
the start and end position.
So essentially, we're
taking all the variants,
and we're actually
lining them up in order.
And that's how we're going
to physically store the data.
So actually,
BigQuery is now going
to collocate the data
that's in the same cluster
in the same place.
So if you have certain
queries, they'll
be optimized by knowing
where to go in which data
you have to access.
In this case, it can reduce
scans of unnecessary data.
Or in the case of
this particular query,
the benefit we get is that now
the data is already grouped.
So when we try to go ahead and
order those and group them,
everything is already
clustered together,
so it's a much
quicker process to do.
Now, you'll notice
here in this one,
the table is still
the same size.
It's still a 23-terabyte
table, but we'll
expect a speed increase due
to the way that it's stored.
So in this, just
like before, this one
is going to process
13 terabytes of data.
So again, it's still a fairly
expensive query for us,
and we're not filtering
in this query, which
is why we're not saving any
of the processing there.
But you can see the
time that it took
here is just under 45 seconds.
So it's over five times faster
by having that data together
in the same place.
The next type of optimization
we're going to do
is starting to optimize
for the types of queries
that we're running.
And so in this case, we
take the clustered table
that we have and then
extract the call sets
for the homozygous reference
calls because we can infer that
from the reference.
So we don't need to store
a duplicate of that.
And then for the no
calls, we actually
pull that out and just store
the no call as a Boolean,
as a true or false
of is it a no call.
So in that case,
we're now not going
to have to unnest that field
to get in there and see that.
We can check the
Boolean and save
on the amount of
data we're processing
and the amount of
data we're storing.
So this table now is
about three times smaller
than the last one, coming in
at just over eight terabytes.
And when we run that same query
on this clustered and compacted
table, we don't have to
process the entire call
record to check if there's a
genotype greater than zero.
We can figure out which records
those are, and in this case,
we did it by processing less
than a terabyte of data.
So in this case, we
process 18 times less data
than the original, meaning the
cost of this query is 5% or so
of what that original one
was, not to mention the time.
We look at this
query now, we run it
in under 10 seconds,
which is 25 times faster
than that original
table that we imported.
So let's look at some of the
other advantages of clustering.
So this query now--
we're doing the same
thing we did before.
We're doing that variant
count, but we're only
going to check chromosome 1.
And the way we're doing
it is with a WHERE clause.
Now, the WHERE clause
is not actually
going to change how
much data we touch.
It's still going to have
to go through and check.
The WHERE clause is great
at restricting how much data
we get back, but
it doesn't really
help us with how much data
we process, generally.
And so if we look at
that when we run it,
you'll see it still processes
13 terabytes of data.
Now, we did this in 30 seconds
as opposed to the four minutes
because we didn't actually have
to do the group and the count,
but we still had to go
through all of that data.
So when we start to use
the clustered table,
so now where it's
actually ordered,
and BigQuery knows where to go
to find different sets of that,
we can see on the right
here that this one
says it may process up
to 13 terabytes still.
Now, the number we give there
is a worst-case scenario.
We don't know all the
time how much data
we're going to access
until we actually do it,
but we can give you
a worst-case guess
of what we may have to touch.
So in this case, it says that
it could run up to 13 terabytes.
But when we actually
run it, you'll
go ahead and see the difference.
So in this case, we
actually only process
one terabyte of data.
Because BigQuery knows
where chromosome 1 has
been clustered, it only has to
hit that particular section,
and it knows it can
ignore all the rest
of the data in the
table because everything
that is collocated together.
Now, it runs in about
the same amount of time,
around 30 seconds,
which lets us know
that the majority
of the time here
is probably the counting and
not the actual finding of it.
So the time is the
same, but processing
it is 13 times less data, again
leading to a direct relation
to our cost reduction.
Now, if we keep optimizing
here, and we use that clustered
and compacted table-- the
one where we had pulled out
the reference and the no calls--
remember that originally
this process, 13 terabytes,
took about 30 seconds.
In this version, we're
now only processing
60 gigabytes of data,
so 200 times less data.
That's barely a blip on the
price sheet at this point.
And we're doing it
five times faster still
in coming in at just under six
seconds to do that same count.
So next, if we look at a
little more complicated query,
if we're checking the
transition to transversion SNPs,
this is a query that will
require accessing almost all
of the data, so we
expect that we're
going to actually have to
touch most of our entire table.
On the originally imported data,
this processed 20 terabytes out
of our original
23-terabyte table
and came in at just
over eight minutes.
So we'll look at a couple
of different things
here of using those same
optimized tables we had before
to see what the impact is
on this particular query.
So again, this calculation
still requires accessing
the same amount of data.
So on a clustered
table, it didn't save us
anything on our actual
cost of computation.
We still had to touch
about 20 terabytes of data,
but we did cut the time
in half and now ran it
in about three and a
half minutes instead
of the original eight.
So when we start
to look at what's
important to your business
for a particular task,
this is an option where even
something like clustering
can still help with some
areas of performance.
And you can find what
the best optimization
is for the types of
queries you're using.
When we run this on that
clustered and compact table,
we've now cut the time
to be less than a minute.
And in this case, that process
is about seven terabytes.
Now, remember, this was
an eight-terabyte table
to begin with, so
we're still touching
almost the entire table.
But it's still a significantly
lower amount of data
that we're having
to touch, and again,
about three times faster, coming
in at just under a minute.
So as we go through
this, we're currently
looking at reviewing some
of the schemas we have
as well as some of these
optimization techniques
to go ahead and see what we can
do to provide optimized schemas
or provide best practices
for certain types of queries.
So again, that's
another area where
we'd love to solicit feedback.
If you've got certain
queries that you're
running or things that
aren't working well
or things you're
looking to optimize,
we've got a mailing
list that we'll
discuss at the end that's got a
number of users of the product
as well as a bunch of
members of our team.
And we can help
try to figure out
what's the best
solution for you and see
if there's something we can
bring back to the community
there as well.
So one of the other
advantages with BigQuery
is using the client libraries,
such as the Python Client
Library, to integrate
with Jupyter notebooks.
So in this, you can connect
your Jupyter notebook directly
to BigQuery, which
we'll use BigQuery
to do the compute and all
of the heavy lifting of any
of the filtering and ordering
to give you your data back,
and you're not depending
on your hosted runtime
to actually do the
hard computations.
So the way this works--
you paste your
query as an argument
when you've imported
the BigQuery library.
You run that, you get the
results back in your notebook,
and if you've got
something in there
already where you're using
a data frame, for example,
you can get that data
back from BigQuery,
put that into the
data frame, and not
have to change the existing
notebooks you have,
and keep using
your same analysis,
just changing the data
source that you're
using on the back end.
Some different options we have
for running notebooks here
include Collaboratory, which
is a product by the research
team at Google that
they provide for use.
And this is hosted
on a Google back
end, although there are
limitations to the runtime
and what you can choose since
it's a hosted environment.
There is Cloud Datalab,
which is a product
that you run in your own
Google Cloud Platform project
and allows you to
host a notebook there
that you want to connect to.
And then we've got a product
that we announced this week
as well that went to beta
called AI Platform notebooks,
and this is essentially
Jupyter notebooks as a service.
And this supports a variety
of different frameworks
and packages, including
TensorFlow and PyTorch,
as well as a lot of
packages pre-installed
that people are used to,
like NumPy and whatnot.
Now, AI Platform notebooks
also has a built in integration
with GitHub.
So we can use that for syncing
or backing up our notebooks
and also using that to
share among other people.
So if you need to share your
notebooks with collaborators
either in your lab, in
your company, with others,
you can do that
through GitHub in a way
that you're already used to.
And we can also attach
different types of CPUs
or attach GPUs to those
platform notebooks as well.
So if you've got tasks where
you're using TensorFlow,
for example, you
can choose which
GPUs you want that are
appropriate for that.
And then, of course, you can
always host your own Jupyter
notebook as well.
So if you already have your
own environment set up,
and you've already
got hosted notebooks,
bring into BigQuery
Client Library,
and you can now utilize
the benefits of BigQuery
with the notebooks that
you've already got.
So let's take a look
at a couple other tools
we have here as well
for doing analysis,
and we're going to look at
Dataproc being one of those.
And then we'll get into a
couple of the partner tools
as well that we have.
So first off, one of the partner
tools that I want to mention,
a recent addition
here, is that we now
have support for Parabricks
through the Marketplace
in Google Cloud Platform.
So Parabricks has written
a GPU-optimized version
of GATK Best Practices and
Deep Variant, and in this case,
they're able to take what
was about a 30-hour run
and turn that into 45 minutes.
So this is now available for you
to launch in Cloud Marketplace.
It runs in your
environment and allows
you to bring services like this
to run in your own project.
The other part to
note is if you're
a developer who's
building tools like this,
this is a way that
you can actually
provide that and make
that available as well
and simplify running that on
Google Cloud's infrastructure
so that your end customers don't
have to figure any of that out.
So let's take a look
at going through here.
We'll start by pulling
it up in Marketplace.
Go ahead and launch
that on compute,
and we can choose the types
of GPUs we want, like a V100.
We can choose how many
we want to attach,
and go ahead and start that.
Once it's up and running, we're
going to SSH into our instance.
And in this case, we're going
to copy our license over
and set a couple of inputs
here and a reference as well.
And those are all
coming from GCS buckets.
We're then going to
go ahead and run that
through this connection.
And as this is
running, again, it's
going to process it, save our
output to its storage bucket
that we defined.
And again, this
shows it in a way
that you can now bring this
directly into your project,
or for the developers
of this tool,
this is a way that they can
deploy and monetize that
as well.
So lastly, I want to talk about
Dataproc at a high level here.
So Dataproc is our managed
service for Apache Spark
and Hadoop environments,
and this can
be used for a variety of tools.
One of them right now that
we're using is for Hale,
and so using this to run a
genomic analysis framework
doing things like
GWAS, and we're
able to run that through
Dataproc, which will handle
all of the nodes for you.
And again, as we look at
the world of notebooks,
we can also then connect the
notebook to that as well.
So if we want to just submit
our job directly to that cluster
or if we want to connect a
notebook to that cluster,
we can then run the job
through the notebook as well.
So I hope that gives a
good introduction to some
of the tools we have in
this space and helps cover
some of the questions
you might have.
Some of the resources
that we discussed here
that are available
with links as well.
And we've got links here to
some of the documentation
and the tutorials that we used.
And then, as I
mentioned as well,
we have a mailing
list at the top.
And that Google Genomics
Discuss mailing list,
you can join that from our
genomics documentation page.
And this list
consists of a number
of users of these products from
around the world as well as
members of our Solutions team
and our Product and Engineering
teams.
So if you have issues,
if you have questions,
if something's not working,
if you're trying something new
that you can't figure out, it's
a great place to go and see
if there's someone who may
have already done that,
if there's other contributors
in the field who can help out,
or if you've got questions
for the engineering team
as to how we can help better
improve these products.
[MUSIC PLAYING]